all right everybody I'm doing something
a little different with the direct
message this week I'm actually in the
suburbs of DC at the moment you could
probably hear the cicadas in the
background and I wanted to do a direct
message about the RNC and everything
that's going on in Cleveland right now
but then last night you all have heard
this already
Miley innopolis was officially banned
for all time for the rest of human
existence he was banned on Twitter you
know he had lost his blueberry vacation
check awhile back
obviously milo and i we've become sort
of comrades were friends we don't agree
on everything I brought him on the show
twice and we've done a couple of other
things where we've had a healthy
exchange of ideas we've gone to UCLA
together where we were protesting for
exercising our rights of free speech
I've gone out of my way to show some of
the differences that I have with Milo
for example I always make the
distinction between the doctrine of
Islam and the various people that are of
Muslim faith and practice their faith
completely differently some totally
nominally and some that are violent
jihadists all the different things that
are in there right now Milo is banned
from Twitter and there is a free speech
issue here and as you guys know I'm all
about free speech and the free exchange
of ideas so first off this is not a
First Amendment issue the First
Amendment of the United States means the
government can't come for your fur for
your free speech I've said many times
before at the moment in 2016 in America
I'm not that afraid that the
government's coming for my free speech I
think we're taking it from ourselves and
I think this is a good example of it you
know Twitter and Facebook and snapchat
and the rest of these things they've
become almost too powerful in their
ability to control speech because these
are now the road wings right these are
the super highways for us to communicate
with each other beyond our ability to
pick up the phone and call the friend
and talk to people on the street and
scream from Town Square our ability to
communicate with literally thousands and
thousands and in Milo's case hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people on
these platforms it's hugely power
and there is something that's happening
right now where it's not actually about
the government but it's about companies
now look they have they're a private
company they're publicly traded right
but they they are allowed to instill
their own Terms of Service which they
did and if they say he violated them
then yes they can ban him so I'm not
saying Twitter can't do what they did
I'm not saying the government is
involved in this in any way I'm just
talking at the principles of the free
exchange of ideas and free speech these
things are under threat right now look
obviously look forget the nitty-gritty
details of what happened in the last day
or so I'm not even fully aware of what
happened there's a lot of tweets I can't
follow
everybody's tweets every second to see
exactly what happened but the point is
that Milo is a provocateur he
intentionally [ __ ] posts and gets people
riled up and look some people respond to
that and some people respond to
something a little more nuanced right
like I might do and get into an idea a
little bit differently but the point is
you know on Twitter there are all kinds
of Nazis look at look at the responses
that ben shapiro Mylo who has fought
with ben shapiro all the time and i was
trying to moderate a debate with them I
hope it's still gonna happen
ben shapiro who was an orthodox jew post
anything on twitter he gets a zillion
nazis photoshopping his head in ovens
and horrific pics put picturing him in
auschwitz all kinds of horrible stuff
muslim people get all kinds of horrible
imagery shown to them gay people people
young i get bag and jew bag and rob
about all the time my look this is their
exercising their free speech if these
people are not calling directly for
violence or acting on violence as far as
i know Milo has never called to harm
anybody
he's never directly called for violence
in any way he's a provocateur sharing
his thoughts and we have to understand
the difference between just words and
actions right like just somebody sitting
in their basement sharing a nazi meme
and and Milo's saying this or that even
if it's directed at a person saying well
I don't like what you're doing to the
girl the girl in Ghostbusters or out in
like the movie or whatever it is and
then he can't control whether his people
say me and thinks her but that's what
the mute buttons for another the block
buttons for the point is we have to
you're out how to have a healthy
exchange of ideas and realize that not
everything that that happens on that
online world is transferred directly
into the real world if real people
started using if people start if a Nazi
Party appeared and said started saying
we're gonna kill all Jews we're gonna
kill all Muslims all this stuff then you
have a problem a direct call for
violence but right now that's not where
we're at and there's an issue here so
they're set for this couple issues here
but to me the primary issue is the power
that these social media companies have
and we can't pretend that they don't
have a political agenda right these are
all pretty left organizations so of
course they're really not gonna like a
guy like Milo cuz it's easy always to
attach attacked stodgy old conservatives
and Republicans Milo represents
something different he's young and cool
and gay and British and blonde and has
this huge groundswell of support by the
way it's his support is from
conservatives and liberals and all sorts
other things I know that because when I
went to UCLA with him
I had liberals in the audience kids
college kids from UCLA saying that they
don't agree with anything he says but
they were there to defend his right to
free speech
so this strikes me a little bit of what
obi-wan said to Darth Vader with you
know if you strike me down I'll become
more powerful than you can possibly
imagine by striking him down here and
banning him from Twitter they're
probably making this movement that much
stronger
anyway it's complex and there's a lot of
things here I would love to talk to
someone from Facebook about this because
they banned a couple people just in the
last week they banned my friend Faisal
and my friend Melissa both who've been
on the show there be reinstated since I
would love to talk to Jack from Twitter
I'd love to talk to any of these tech
people so they're welcome to come on the
show I'm not trying to enflame anything
any further I genuinely want to have
this conversation and by the way right
now you can go on Twitter and you can
check the Ayatollah Khomeini's Twitter
account he regularly calls for another
Holocaust you can see what's going on
with the president of Turkey who right
now is the midst of literally just
disassembling democracy there and
arresting protesters and sacking judges
and not letting people leave the country
they have no problem with him being on
there so there's just there's an
inconsistency in the way they apply
these rules there's just a lot of stuff
here let's try to have a mature
discussion about it
and my guests this week so as I said we
normally do this from the studio in Los
Angeles I'm in DC right now my guest
this week is Michael Ian Black comedian
actor writer great guy he is big in
fighting the trolls and we have a really
interesting discussion about fighting
trolls and Twitter Nazis we talk about
Milo now we shot this last week so
everything that you're going to see is
not about what happened yesterday and
today we shot it last week but it's a
great discussion about these very issues
so the timing is perfect and I
appreciate it and I'll be back in studio
soon enough and as always thank you guys
for your support here we go